Okay, everyone. Uh, welcome to the DDPS
seminar. Uh, before we introduce our
invited speaker, let's go over some
rules and logistics. First of all,
please mute yourself during the talk.
But if you have an origin questions, you
can unmute and ask questions or use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in Q&A session at the
end. Second, today's DDPS seminar is
open to external audience. Therefore, no
classified discussion is allowed. So,
please watch out. Uh, finally, the talk
today will be recorded and uploaded in
our YouTube channel. That's about it.
Now, let me briefly uh introduce our
speaker today. It is an honor to host uh
professor Sid Mishra who is a chair
professor of applied mathematics at ETH
Jurich where he has the computational
and applied mathematics laboratory. He's
also the director of computational
science jurik and a core faculty member
of the ETH AI center. Mishara's uh
research is focused on the design and
analysis of numerical and AI and
algorithms for uh simulating um physical
systems and their applications to
astrophysics, geopysics, climate
science, engineering and biology.
Mishira is an elected fellow of the
European Academy of Science and the
recipient of the awards such as Kat
Prize of ICAM
uh Dal Dquist Prize of Siam Bone Mrs.
prizes of GAM and Rosa prize of ETH. He
has been an invited speaker at leading
inter international conferences
including the international congress of
mathematics and the international
congress of basic uh sciences. Today
Michelle will talk about AI for
datadriven simulation in physics which
is a very exciting talk.
Now uh before
before I pass the button to you the
tradition of the DDPS seminar uh here is
I always ask the speaker some informal
question if that is okay m
>> yes of course of course
>> okay okay cool um
so what motivated you when you are young
and um and make you jump into this
awesome exciting
computational science and recently this
AI uh
>> okay uh to begin with my undergraduate
degree is in physics mostly physics a
bit of math but mostly physics so I
think of myself as a failed physicist
right because I and then when I when I
went into graduate school I realized
that I was better in math than physics
so I have sort of a dual background
>> and then when I was actually trying to
do math particularly and I was always
interested in math that is relevant for
physics. Uh PTE partial differential
equations they became sort of my main
topic. Uh have a lifelong love affair
with them. And then I realized very
quickly that you need numerical methods
because there's only so much that you
can do with your pen and paper. And uh
that's the starting point into
computational science. And as you will
see, there's a very nice motivation, a
very natural motivation of why a
computational scientist who's been
working all the time with sort of
traditional numerical methods realizes
that they hit a limit and then you have
to use an alternative and this is where
AIdriven methods are or datadriven
methods are and you'll see I think I'll
provide the motivation in that sense.
>> Awesome. Well, thank you. That was very
nice. A perfect answer and uh the stage
is yours.
>> Okay. Thank you so much Yu for this
first of all for the invitation and
second for this lovely introduction and
also for the informal question. I know a
lot of people are joining. So I will
jump right in about the topic and uh
let's see. Yeah. So let me start with
some examples just to motivate what's
going on right and the kind of problems
that I personally am interested in.
Good. So the first example as I said is
from tsunami simulations. So just
imagine that there's an earthquake off
the coast of Greece Creed in this
particular case and because of the
earthquake the water gets displaced the
ocean water and it sets off tsunami
waves that are going to sort of track
across the entire Mediterranean basin.
And people are interested in discrete
locations for instance um off the coast
of Greece and off the coast of Italy and
they want to measure what is the wave
height at some buoys just outside the
coast something which looks like this
right so this will be the basis of a
tsunami forecast so there are buoys all
over the Mediterranean or the Pacific or
the Atlantic and this kind of recording
or this kind of prediction is necessary
to issue a evacuation warning. This is
one example which is more from the
sciences and another example from
engineering is an example that was uh is
joint work with people at IBM. So there
is a race car company Delara. They
design race cars for instance for
Ferrari and so on. And you want to
optimize the design of race cars right?
So to do so you need to predict
aerodynamic forces. You need to change
uh things like the location of the fin
or the in the sail in the front or
something like that. and you want to see
how much is the are the aerodynamic
forces optimized how much is the drag
reduced for instance right so these are
the kind of problems that we're
interested in one from an example from
science and an example from engineering
and we all know how these problems are
solved currently so what you do is first
you write down a mathematical model and
more often than not the vast majority of
cases these are PTE partial differential
equations and we know that they are like
language of nature and they cover an
immense sort of diversity of physical
phenomena all the way from the smallest
scales to the largest and I think at
less
at all possible scales. So this is this
is standard you write down a
mathematical model. We also know that we
cannot find a solution formula for PES.
That's why I moved into computational
mathematics or numerical simulation to
begin with and we have all kinds of
numerical techniques finite elements
finite difference find volume and so on
which are very very effective and they
have been around for quite a long time
and also from our lab we do everything
from I don't know simulating supernova
core collapse to the dynamics of strata
cumulus clouds to as I said um for
instance 3D laser manufacturing there
are many many examples where this
successful and I think at less
of these kind of examples every day
right so this is so successful so what's
the what about the use cases so for
instance for tsunami simulations you
solve the shallow water equations and
you get this propagation of the tsunami
waves across the midterranean similarly
for the race car simulations one has to
solve some version of navia stokes uh
rans navia stokes equations and you get
the aerodynamic forces uh pressure shear
and so on on the body so this is a very
very established let's say pipeline. So
what's the issue? What's the catch? So I
think all of us who are joining this
seminar probably know this that the key
key catch in some sense is computational
cost right because this these
simulations expensive just to give you
an idea of the scale of the simulations.
Uh this is an academic example from my
lab but I think it's instructive. So
this is just Navia talks direct
numerical simulations. So you start with
some initial conditions and then you
want to propagate the solution which
looks very complicated. As you can see a
single simulation if I used our old CPU
code would have been almost 5,000 CPU
node hours but we have a very optimized
GPU code. So this enables us to reduce
it by a factor of 50 to approximately
100 uh node hours on a supercomput.
But uh this is uh not good enough and
the reason is obvious because this uh
turbulent fluid flow small changes in
the initial conditions can lead to
dramatic changes in the in the solution.
So you need to do some sort of
uncertainty quantification. You need to
repeat the simulation many many many
times or else if you're doing some
forcing do it over very long time scales
and this will blow up the cost because
uh if you do a thousand of these
simulations you are easily with 100,000
load hours and as you can see this is a
very very expensive almost unaffordable
proposition. So it's very clear that
whenever you have these many query
problems where the PD solver needs to be
called again and again again you need to
solve PDS fast otherwise this pipeline
breaks down. So that's the first first
point. What is in these examples? This
is a very good um illustration of this
because state-of-the-art tsunami
simulations they take maybe this is down
to half an hour but it doesn't make a
difference. It's between half an hour
and an hour with uncertainty
quantification. And the issue with that
is that it just is you need real time
right half an hour the tsunami has
already reached many of these places in
the basin. So this is just useless in
some sense to make predictions. And for
the flow past the race car, it's in 3D
very complex simulation. So it takes
about 500 node hours per shape. This is
even a low resolution computation. And
just imagine when you try to do
optimization, this is just unaffordable.
So you have to sort of solve PDS fast in
some setting. But I think what's even
more troublesome in some sense is the
fact that to solve a PD we have to write
it down first, right? And in many many
cases we can do that. But in many many
more cases particularly when we're
dealing with real world phenomena we
can't do that and I'm sure at Livermore
you have that situation. Let's take a
classic example the earth system itself
right. So in the earth system we know
that the flow of um the ocean and the
atmosphere is navia stokes of some
version and uh radiation is radiative
transfer. But if you just imagine the
other processes there is land there is
um there is forest cover vegetation uh
aerosols all these things there are no
sort of um abinio first principles
derivations that you can make so there
are many many things that you sweep
under the rug and you don't really know
the physics um at a first principles
level right so in robotics people call
this as a simtoreal gap but we have
exactly the same situation here that
even if you make the best possible
simulation
your predictions are still off right so
this is so either the PDEs are um slow
to solve or hard to solve or it's
difficult to write them down so what is
it that we can sort of uh do to sort of
salvage the situation a little bit right
so one thing that we should remember is
that in most real world applications we
do have some data the idea behind
datadriven modeling nowadays is to
combine data and physics so that you can
you can either solve PD P is fast or you
can s sort of do it in situations where
the PD itself is unknown or P system of
PD are unknown. So this is the problem
that I want to address. Now how do I
address this problem? So it's a learning
problem, right? So this is the basic
idea. It's a learning problem and there
are different quantities that you can
target to learn. So I think there is a
consensus in the community now that what
you should really target are what are
called solution operators of PDS mean
these are very very well- definfined
objects in some sense. So for instance
if you have elliptic or steady state PD
like darc flow so this is a permeability
which is your input a function and your
output is the solution of the PD another
function. So the solution operator is
mapping the input to the output uh and
it sort of predicts systemic behavior
right similarly for a time dependent PD
like let's say the compressible oiler
equations which I illustrated here this
could be the mapping that takes the
initial data to solution at a later time
or trajectories of the solution. So in
some sense uh uh PTE solution operators
exemplify or they describe the entire
behavior the entire gamut of behavior
that the PD entails right and this is
what we want to learn from data. So
remember that it's very important that
this is actually
this is a solution operator. It's a
mapping which takes a infinite
dimensional function and returns an
infinite dimensional function. And we
need to because we're talking about data
we need to specify some sort of
description of the data that we are
talking about right so all that you have
to do is to take uh a probability
measure on functions mean these are very
well definfined quantities then we
assume that we have access so we we take
some random samples and we have access
to the effect or the action of the
solution operator on the samples and
then this forms you forms the data of
the problem. Needless to say, there
could be some noise, some measurement
noise here, but I'm going to stick to
the noise free case. Extensions to the
noise, noisy case are fairly
straightforward. So now remember that we
have mathematically formulated this
problem as learning what is called a
push forward of the solution operator of
the PTE given the measure that is there
on the data, the distribution that is
there on the data. So it's a very well-
definfined mathematically sound problem.
However, the issue is that and how are
we going to learn this? So, it's very
clear that this the age of AI means we
have very powerful illustrations that I
don't have to repeat here. And the key
to AI in some sense these days is deep
neural networks of different types. It
could be MLPS, it could be CNN's, it
could be transformers, whatever. But the
point is that these are maps uh deep
neural networks are maps which take a
finite dimensional input and they map
you on to a finite dimensional input uh
output. Now input and output dimensions
can both be very large but they are not
infinite whereas what did I tell you
that our problem is essentially an
infinite dimensional problem. So our
inputs are functions outputs are
functions. So there is a dichotomy
there's a gap here right that you have
to project down an infinite dimensional
problem or lift up a finite dimensional
construction which is what neural
networks are and in some sense this is
numerical analysis because numerical
analysis sort of moves between or
scientific computing for that matter
between the infinite dimensions the
level of the PTE and a numerical method
which is a finite dimensional
construction so there are many analoges
here so there are different ways to do
this to sort of bridge this divide One
way which was I would say formalized at
least by people at Caltech with Nick
Nick Kovachki as the first author some
years ago is why don't you take neural
networks. So these are maps in final
dimensions. So all that they do is that
they're compositions and at each layer
of the composition you take an input
vector right you do a matrix vector
multiply add another vector bias vector
and apply pointwise nonlinearity. So
that's a neural network and what Nick
and his co-authors suggested is why
don't we extend this to infinite
dimensions more or less u what Latin
would call mutatism mutandis which is
just with an obvious extension and here
of course now we don't have uh vectors
anymore we have functions so this guy is
replaced by a function and for matrix
vector multiply there's a very natural
canonical extension which is a kernel
integral operator so you take your input
throw it against the kernel integrate
now this will be a function And now you
apply the nonlinearity the so-called
activation function pointwise. So
essentially this is revisiting what are
called kernel integral operators but you
have to choose your um discretization
carefully right because otherwise you
cannot really sort of implement this on
a computer. So this is still to be done
at a finite dimensional level. So you
have to sort of think about
computational complexity in this
setting. So one particular choice of the
kernel for instance was done by the same
group of authors and it's called FIA
neural operators. It's it's around for a
while and it's very very popular and
powerful. So their idea was that you
keep everything intact just change the
or choose a kernel to be a convolution
but you instantiate you uh sort of
realize it in 4 years. So what you do is
that you have the you this is your
classical formula. So you take a
function take its 4 year transform apply
a learnable 4y year multiplier go back
to physical space with inverse 4year
transform and then apply the
nonlinearity pointwise. So that is FNO
FIA neural operator and this is a very
very powerful architecture in some sense
it's widely used uh there's also very
solid theory particularly from me and my
collaborators but the basic idea is that
you have convolutions which are
implemented in a non-local manner and uh
activations which are local pointwise
right but this is not the only choice
this is a good choice we'll see later
what are some of the implications a
choice that we made uh from my lab some
years ago is called convolutional neural
operators where we kept the structure as
it is but instead of having a non-local
fier implementation of convolution we
did a local uh sort of a pointwise
implementation of convolution but the
big change for us is that we changed
this local activation into a non-local
activation and the reason why we did
this it comes from some mathematical
depth but it mostly people who do
spectral methods know this that if you
apply nonlinearity pointwise to any any
sort of function which is let's say band
limited then you end up generating high
frequencies. So imagine that you have 10
frequencies sin 10x and take the square
of it you get sin 20x. So this can lead
to aliasing which is the generation of
wrong high frequencies which can create
problems. So to sort of fight against it
to alleviate it we said no no we have a
smart way in which we can sort of change
this to a non-local activation. So there
are these sort of differences, subtle
differences and do this really matter.
So here's an example. Uh this is an
operator that is well defined. You take
Navia Stokes in 2D very very well posed
and then take some initial datam in the
velocity space and then move it forward.
Uh this is how it looks in vorticity and
what all methods do well in this case
and you can see the numbers there. But
the key here is to remember recollect
that this is an infinite dimensional
problem. However, I have to discretise
it right otherwise you can't implement
it on a computer. So I fix a resolution
at which I discretize. In this
particular case it's 64 squared. So if I
have just taken a CNN, a CNN would be
this architecture but with just a local
activation then what happens is that the
error when you change the grid
resolution at test time it increases in
both directions. You course in the error
goes up you refine the error goes up.
This is because it never learned the
operator. It only learned a particular
one finite dimensional representation of
it. With FNO the situation is much
better but still there are these
aliasing errors that I told you about.
You can even see it visually and as you
refine as coren in particular you see
that the error goes up with CNO it has
been designed to fight against this. It
has been constructed to be structure
preserving then what happens is that you
get a flat line. So it seamlessly
generalizes across different grids. So
this is an additional design feature
that you can endow an architecture and
machine learning model because you're
dealing with these kind of operators
infinite dimensional objects. So this is
this an important point that I wanted to
make. But uh this is not the only choice
of kernels. You can choose other kinds
of kernels. Right? So one particular
choice of kernels is linear kernels.
FNO, CNO. These were based on linear
kernels. But you can make it as general
as possible. That will imply nonlinear
kernels here. Right? And one particular
nonlinear kernel has attracted a lot of
attention in last five years because it
is attention. This is from transformers.
So this is a structure of the nonlinear
kernel. It uses a soft max as the kernel
here. And as it's it has very nice
theoretical properties. It has
universality and so on. But what is
annoying here is the scaling the
computational cost because as you can
see it's quadratic. To update the value
at this point, what you have is um all
kinds of you you collect information
which is broadcasted from all these
points but you weigh them with
information that is clean from all the
other points. So you have two all to all
maps all to one maps and that becomes an
all to-all map which is quadratic in the
number of tokens. So this is very
unaffordable essentially but from
computer vision there are techniques
which allow us to scale this u in 2D and
3D for instance. So first technique is
what is called patching which is just
finite volume methods. So you don't uh
work with pointwise data. You work with
some learned averages inside what are
called patches or cells. In my in my
interpretation and this works quite well
but uh if you have very small cells or
small patch sizes there's another trick
called windowed attention which comes
again from the computer vision community
where attention is now localized. So you
just have localized inside this big
windows. It's like domain decomposition
for those who do numerical methods. It's
like domain decomposition. You divide
the domain into subdomains. You apply
attention at each step inside each
subdomain. But the whole point about
attention was this global information
transfer. And this is affected through
the fact that when you you have a
multi-layer structure. So when you
change the layer, when you go to the
next layer, you just move the windows or
shift the windows. And then what happens
is that then there is global transfer
information. points which are not
talking to each other, they start
talking to each other and you have a
global information transfer. So this uh
what we did is uh in a paper last year I
even saw that Max my student he even
joined this meeting so he's probably
listening in and uh so this is uh
essentially from his work. So what you
do is that you just take this
architecture this twin transformers and
you stack them in a nice manner and then
you end up getting a operator
transformer that is scalable. It is a
universal approximator of continuous
operators. It has all nice theoretical
properties. So you can you can use
convolutions, you can use the tension.
There are different choices that you can
make it at this level it doesn't make a
difference. Later on in 10 15 minutes
you will see that there is going to be a
difference but um yeah let's say for the
personal equation the transformer was
slightly better for the wave equation
convolution was slightly better they're
generally comparable to each other. So
the point is that as long as you have a
two-dimensional cartitionian domain uh
then across a wide variety of benchmarks
not just from our lab but from many many
other groups you have seen a lot of
success of FNO CNO different kinds of
transformers and so on. So I would say
that in 2D on academic test cases this
is a solved problem in some sense you
know how to approximate operators
but this was precisely my caveat right
because uh most domains in practice in
engineering in the sciences these are
not cartisian domains so this is what we
have somehow solved as a community but
these are the sort of more towards the
real domains right the race car as an
example so then your models should have
the flexibility to work with arbitrary
data and this or arbitrary point clouds
and this is um this is a choice that one
has to make. So you can use graphs, you
can use graph neural networks. I know
many people in the national labs in the
US are very fond of graph neural
networks. So graph neural networks are
uh because you can take these point
clouds and you can interpret them. You
can build graphs out of them and then
what happens is that you just uh
transfer information on this graph. So
in particular to update at this point
you collect information from the
neighbors through some MLPS for instance
and then you sort of uh aggregate the
information for instance with sum and
then you process it through another MLP.
So that's a message passing neural
network very standard graph neural
network. Uh from our lab we have our own
uh sort of structure construction of
this. It's hierarchical. It's a let's
say a graph neural network on steroids
with some nice design features. And the
advantage with graphs is that you have a
lot of generality, right? You can you
can discretize or solve PDS on a circle
or flow past an air foil or some elastic
deformations. So there's a lot of
generality and it's also very accurate
means there are tons of numbers here.
But that's uh you can just believe me
that the graphs are very very accurate.
But the problem is that they're not
necessarily efficient since in some of
these cases it took us two days to train
some of these models even in 2D because
it's very expensive and the reason is
that there's a lot of sparse memory
access in graphs and that sort of blows
up your compute. So we have to if you
want to scale it further towards 3D 2D I
think graphs are very good perhaps for
some 3D problems graphs are very good
but to really scale it to industrial
scale problems in 3D I'm not convinced
that graphs are the solution so what can
solve it so one option would be to
combine the nice features of
convolutions or transformers with that
of graphs right so graphs is generality
transformers is efficiency and
scalability so there are different ways
to do this One attempt from us recently
is what is called geometry aware
operator transformers. So what you do is
that so you have a grid here that is um
essentially instantiated as a graph and
you want to go from a graph to a to a
cartisian grid let's say as an example
but it could be some other grid a latent
grid. You do this using graph neural
networks. There's a lot of technology
let's say a lot of huristics that go
into this but this is essentially the
construction that you go from a um very
complex point cloud to something better
behaved like a structured grid as an
example. Once you are on a structured
grid or let's say coarse unstructured
grid you can use transformers readily
and then you go back. So this is sort of
the construction transform to a latent
grid work in the latent space and come
back right so this is this is basically
the idea and this is a very very
efficient it's is as accurate as graphs
in the paper there are many examples but
is much more efficient. uh I I'll give
you some examples in a sec. And because
of this efficiency, we can really go to
industrial scale problems. So let me
give you some examples. So this is uh
data set that is available from people
at MIT. It's called driveet++
8,000 car shapes. What these people did
is that they took different shapes of
passenger cars, computed the flow around
the car, and they're interested in sort
of surface quantities, surface pressure,
sheer stress, and so on. And uh each
surface is approximately 2 million
nodes. This is RANs. So that's that's
sort of the mesh resolution that they
looked at. And for instance, our model
here did very very well. It was
significantly more accurate than some of
the leaderboard models. And be that as
it may, the key point is now this a
three-dimensional industrial scale data
set, industrial scale problem. to do the
computations to generate the data the
people at MIT took them 300 node hours
per sample per shape which is insane
right but that's the number that you're
talking about but uh for the model
itself to do inference it took 1/3 a
second or one 0.4 4 seconds extremely
fast right so this is the promise of AI
methods if they're accurate and if they
scale well then you can get six seven
eight orders of magnitude speed up so
this is an example of that you can up
the ante you can go to ales scale
computations so this is driver ML from
Neil Ashton who is currently at Nvidia
so what Neil did is that he took ales
simulations roughly of the same car
shapes only 500 because it's much more
expensive but uh And on the surface
there are 10 million surface nodes. And
go does a fairly good job at handling
this. And to the best of our knowledge
at the moment it's the only model that
can handle the full surface mesh at one
go because of its in inbuilt efficiency.
You can do aircraft simulations. This is
an example. This is from the NASA CRM
benchmark. Uh and again it's a full
aircraft and rans of course not less.
and you can still uh the point that I'm
trying to make is at the moment I would
say that this is a bit of a breakthrough
not just from our model but from the
community we're able to scale these
models to sort of industrial scale
benchmarks in 3D that's that's that's
very pleasing it's not just on some 2D
academic test cases uh but you can you
can make it harder you can make your
task harder and I would argue among the
hardest tasks are PTE whose solutions
are chaotic and a multiscale And what
better than turbulent fluid flows right
and this is an example uh DNS in this
setting you have threedimensional nav
talks um forget about complex geometries
let's focus on simple geometries in this
case and what you see here are
simulations with respect to viscosity
method
I think I alluded to it before and what
you can see here is the pointwise
amplitude of the kinetic energy so there
are this is you can already see a lot of
small scale structure there's a
turbulent flow But what is very
interesting here is that uh I don't know
if you focus for instance on this uh
little bit here the quadrant near the
origin you see significant differences
between different samples and these have
been generated by tiny tiny little
perturbations to the tailor green
initial data. So there are two features
here. It's multiscale, lots of different
scales as chaotic. Small changes imply
large divergence in trajectories.
Now we want to learn the solution
operator of these equations. Right? Let
me take whatever machine learning
architecture that you want. It doesn't
matter. We took a combination of local
and global convolutions. Uh something
called convolutional 4 operator. And
then you see this behavior that first of
all all the fine scale details are
washed out what you end up are just the
let's say the average details but and
what is second is that there's no
variance here
there's significant amount of
variability in the here at the ground
truth none of it here so we you could
argue this is a poor model and if you
change the model you'll get better
results but in a recent paper which was
pub not published but on archive with
some colleagues at uh Google research.
What we first discovered or found out is
a mechanism by which this happens. And
this is a very very interesting
mechanism in the sense that um
that uh neural networks you know they
they are in some sense universal
approximators. So one thinks of neural
networks as being able to approximate
anything. But to make them match
parameters with your observed data or
with your data, you need to train them.
And training is done with gradient
descent. That's more or less the
universal way of training. So to train
with gradient descent, you need to have
well- behaved gradients. If your
gradients are very small or very large,
then your neural network doesn't train.
So lots of tricks have been used to make
uh gradients well behaved, which means
that gradients can't be too large,
right? And this is why some people say
that neural networks operate at the edge
of chaos. They they cannot represent
chaos. They're at the edge of chaos.
Essentially, they're insensitive to
small perturbations. If you have tiny
pertibbations, then you don't really see
them. Once you make this assumption,
this hypothesis, and you go back to my
problem, I'm trying to learn a map which
is very sensitive to small
perturbations, right? It's a chaotic
map. So, this is my ground truth. I take
small perturbations and I average
against the small perturbations because
I'm interested in average quantities
apply my neural network give it the same
input then what happens is that this is
insensitive doesn't see the perturbation
the neural network the ground truth sees
the perturbation so now you have this
form here and then you can sort of
expand this into two terms uh this is
sometimes called the bias variance uh
decomposition but uh this is this is
just technicality so you decompose it
into two terms terms. There's one term
which is just the variance of your
underlying operator. It has nothing to
do with neural networks and this is a
large quantity for chaotic flows. So you
can't you can't make it zero. It will be
large. On the other hand, this is a
quantity that you can optimize for and
the best you can do is to set this equal
to this which means that your neural
network just collapses to the mean. And
so this is what what really happens
here, right? that you have you have no
variance and you have a collapse to the
mean and these hypothesis tell us that
you cannot approximate this kind of
chaotic maps very very sensitive maps
with neuronet networks but what can you
do so this is where some of my previous
work uh has come in handy because we
understand that for a fluid dynamic
equations uh essentially in a sto you
cannot really this deterministic
solution operator is very very poorly
behaved so you cannot approximate it in
any meaningful sense even with
traditional numerical methods. What you
can do is that thankfully for us that
chaos there's some statistical order to
deterministic chaos the distributions.
So if you take a distribution of the
initial data distribution and function
space and you look at the resulting
distribution as a function of time of
the solution this map is well behaved
and this map is much more stable. It's
difficult to prove it rigorously but
everyone doing fluid dynamics knows that
this map is well behaved. So in that
sense uh statistical computation going
directly from here to here is feasible
going through each of these bits is
infeasible. So the idea is to learn the
conditional distribution right given the
initial datam learn the distribution of
the solutions that that you're going to
get and conditional sampling is very
popular in machine learning these days
means all text to image generators use
it and almost all of them are using some
form of diffusion models. Now, diffusion
models are a way to go between
distributions, right? You go from a
target distribution to a noisy
distribution by adding noise and then
when you're inferring, you sort of take
out the noise by denoising. And this is
what is denoising diffusion what it
does, right? And we sort of took this
ideas and we sort of translated them
into a setting.
This leads to an algorithm which is
called genf. And the idea is it's a
conditional diffusion algorithm. So you
noise the this is the initial condition
for instance this is a solution at a
later time in a forward step you add
noise so that you go to essentially a
gausian right a gausian measure with
noise and in the reverse step you sort
of given some noisy distribution known
noisy distribution and given the initial
conditions you can sort of take out
remove the noise and you get back the
solution. Okay, this is uh saying it
simply and all this is done with uh
stoastic differential equations uh in
this case some reverse SD and to train
this uh all that you do is that given
your input your sort of condition
initial condition for instance given
some noisy sample given the level of
noise all that you all that your neural
network is going to do is to d noiseise
is to come back to the ground truth
right so this is sort of the basis of
diffusion models now it's the same
neural network. This is precisely the
neural network that was not able to sort
of take this extreme sensitivity into
account. Right? So it has the same
features as before but the way in which
we employ it or deploy it rather is uh
different. Right? So now all that we're
doing is that we we are just removing
some noise which is uh which is a let's
say well behaved process in some sense
but then we're adding this noise during
the SD. So these two things somehow
cancel out. They compensate and in the
paper we show that this can you can even
prove for some simple cases that you'll
get the conditional distribution. So
does it work in practice? It works in
theory and it does work in practice. So
this is the same example as before and
this was what the machine learning model
gave and this is what my diffusion model
gives. Right? It's sort of it's almost
impossible to distinguish and similarly
for the vorticity. So the samples look
very realistic but that's not enough.
You you want the statistical quantities
to be good. So everything from the mean
to the variance particularly the
variance. Remember that traditional
neural network it simply did not have
any variance. It could not generate
variance with such small perturbations.
This one gets absolutely the right
variance and distribution spectra all
these quantities are done correctly. So
this is one way I think perhaps the only
way in some sense to handle this kind of
very complex uh PTE where distribution
learning is the only way to go and uh
you can scale it to real world right
once you do it for some academic cases.
We know how to scale it to the real
world and these are some examples. Uh
this is for instance a turbulent
boundary layer the shock wave hitting a
turbulent bubble. This is essentially
smoke coming out of a chimney. all the
cases, realistic samples, statistical
fidelity and at inference these are very
fast right these are 1 to two seconds
maybe the biggest model was 4 seconds
but uh we generated the data it was 15
hours so you still have four five six
orders of magnitude speed up so again
you can even handle very very complex uh
PTE with complex multiscale phenomena so
now needless to say after having done
all this hard work in principle uh when
you apply it to some of these other
problems that I started out with tsunami
simulation this takes uh this is some
work some years ago and this is very
very fast you know it it really takes uh
1,000th of a second 1 millisecond even
the race car simulation okay this is a
one one number off this is uh 10 the
minus one so I I made a mistake when I
was making it but still compared to 500
node hours this is uh this is a massive
massive difference so in these examples
you can see that there is uh there's a
big payoff
Right. So, but still I have five six
minutes left in my talk. There is there
is a caveat and there's a very very
important caveat and this caveat comes
from the fact that what's the amount of
data what's the cost in some sense of
learning these models not at the time of
inference but how much data do I need to
feed them right the good news is all
these models so CNO FNO the graph based
method rigno the graph and
transformer-based method gen CFD all of
them scale what it means is that if you
put more data then the error Whatever
error that you have the right error
metric this decays as a function of uh
the number of samples uh this you can
this can even be justified with some
theory there are a couple of papers that
we wrote and other people have written
and that's a good news right more data
means better results but the problem is
that the constants are poor and this
alpha it's at best 0.5 at best you know
it's always less than 0.5 and then even
to get 1% error you need 10,000 samples
you you know that's roughly the roughly
the scale. So all the examples that I
presented were mostly of the order of
thousand to 10,000 samples. Now you'll
ask what are the applications where you
have that weather and climate yes you
have a lot of data and that's why it
works machine learning works very well
in that domain but for most engineering
you don't have this high amounts of data
right so how do you do can you scale
your models better is there a way route
by which this hard problem can be solved
now you can look at for inspiration
modern AI systems Gemini different kinds
of chat GPT these are able to you know
of course they have been uh means they
they they can do things with a single
prompt, right? Almost almost no data. So
how how do they do that right? So you
can think of it in some sense by looking
at what are called foundation models
which are the base behind uh chat GPT
and so on. And the point about
foundation models is that there is no
consensus on what they are. But a rough
idea would be that uh this is trained on
multiple distributions you know text
images different kinds of text different
kinds of images and this goes into a big
machine learning model billions or
trillions of parameters these days
learns representations
and then you look at one particular
domain for instance I don't know object
recognition and then you take this model
and you sort of hyperloize it adapt it
to that particular situation and it
turns out that for physics there is a
very natural road map by which This
picture can be extended and let me just
uh give you that uh that as a data point
here. So remember that uh underlying
physical systems there are PTEs. This
could also be system of PDS just imagine
heat equation, wave equation, LLAS
equation, Navia Stokes or whatever
multifysics that you have. For each PTE
you can change the coefficients,
boundary conditions, domain initial
conditions. This gives rise to
operators. So infinitely many PDs
infinitely many operators on the on the
y-axis here. And what a foundation model
would do is that it will take some of
these PDs finitely many of course and
some of these operators train the model
on them and then at the time of
deployment what are called downstream
tasks with fine-tuning it could take the
same PTE but a different operator or it
could take a completely different PTE
and try to see how much of
representations are useful. So that's
the basic idea behind a foundation mode.
It turns out that for PDEs a priority if
you if you have learned gone to a PTE
class particularly from mathematicians
you'll see that uh you start with
elliptic PDEs lelasses equation then you
go to heat equation then you go to wave
equation for each PD there are different
techniques there are different numerical
methods there doesn't seem to be these
are like isolated silos or islands in an
ocean right and there doesn't seem to be
any connection but this entire picture
this needs to rely on some connections
so a priority it shouldn't work in some
sense but we will not find it out unless
until we try it out. So this was our
attempt uh and the paper is again max
first author this has been there since
last year and uh you can you can
download the code you can download the
models and the idea is precisely to do
that to train on some fixed set of PTE
and then deploy it for let's say PDEs
that have not been seen before and this
is still a proof of concept I would say
and um yeah so the model itself is just
a transformer that I've just described
for scalable operator transformer but
the foundation model is not about the
machine learning model it's more about
the data and what kind of data did we do
remember that we can only choose
finitely many PDs so just for
convenience um perhaps not for
convenience but based on some huristics
we chose just two PDS the incompressible
Navia Stokes equations with high uh
reol's number and there are two
operators from that periodic boundary
conditions and the compressible oiler
equations these are the two PDS that I
know the best. So these were the PDEs
that were there in pre-training and uh
then we have a model and we have
different uh versions of the model. So
roughly speaking we have uh data set
with 5 million image pairs and we
trained a model. Our largest model was
630 million parameters. So this was this
was the scale at which you operated. In
principle you can take larger models but
this is the scale at which you operated.
So that's the pre-training and we're not
interested in this right? This is where
you do what the pre-trainer does. But
what we're interested is in downstream
tasks where you can deploy this
pre-training model. And there are 15 of
them. Some of them are with the Navia
Stokes and the oiler equations. But many
of them are not. Many of them add new
phenomena for instance transport or
gravity and some of them are completely
different like the wave equation or
reaction diffusion equations or posh
mold's equation elliptic equations which
are not at all seen during the during
the pre-training process. So this is uh
the setup still academic still 2D
cartian grade but I think it sort of
addresses some of the key issues whether
this entire thing is feasible or not and
how do we do this remember that I have a
model which has been trained and roughly
speaking this model takes some inputs uh
embeds them into a latent space and then
recovers them back right so what we
often do is that this latent space is
what we transfer so instead of um
starting from scratch We transfer the
latent space from the foundation model
and we keep the embeddings and the
recovery for perhaps from scratch. So
this is roughly roughly the picture
here. There are a little bit more
details and does it work? How am I going
to quantify this? There are 15 different
PDs or operators that I've tested on and
I'm not going to show you pictures of
all 15. So we need some metrics and
there are two natural metrics that come
in. So remember that all that I cared
about is how many how few samples I can
get by right earlier I needed thousand
samples how few samples that I can get
by and this is what I call as a sample
efficiency gain and I measure it with
respect to fn so let's say fno takes a
th00and samples to get I don't know
whatever 20% error in this particular
case how many uh or 2% I don't remember
but how many samples do I need for my
foundation model and in this particular
case it's about 50 samples Right. So
this is roughly roughly the idea that I
gain a factor of uh 20 in this
particular case. The other metric could
be that you have fixed number of samples
let's say 100 fn or whatever model that
you have makes a certain amount of error
by starting with the foundation model.
How much can I reduce this and this will
be the second gain which is the gain in
accuracy and we have quantified it for
all the 15 but this is again uh you can
you can look at the table in the paper
but let me just summarize it right. So
the summary is at least at this scale
the foundation model works very very
well. Why is that? Because our largest
foundation model it is 50 times on an
average more sample efficient than an
FNO for the same task. What does it mean
that if FNO needed thousand samples this
will require roughly 20 samples right
and this is you can generate 20 samples
not a thousand. And the second thing is
that in terms of accuracy also it's a
factor of 10. So if you have 20% error
on an average now you get 2% error at
let's say with 100 samples roughly
speaking. So this works. The other
things that work is that there is very
nice scaling in the sense that as I
increase my model size the these metrics
get better. So that's a good thing. The
third thing that happens is that at
least when we wrote it it was the
state-of-the-art foundation model. uh
and I think it still is because the
other models are not as good. There
there are other models around. There is
one from Flat Iron in New York. There's
one from people in Shinua University.
There are other models that are coming
up. But uh and they they also do a good
job. So it's sort of this field is sort
of rapidly emerging. And the final point
which is perhaps worth making is that I
said that there is not a huge difference
between convolutions and attentionbased
uh new operators. That is very much true
when you look at them as uh on a
particular task. But as foundation
models, one is seems to be better.
Transformers seem to be better at
assimilating information from different
uh sources.
So I'm almost coming to an end. I'll
take a couple of minutes and I'll wrap
up. So just let me give you an example
just to illustrate what's going on. So
remember that my foundation model has
been trained on the two equations of
fluid dynamics, compressible and
incompressible. I'm going to test it on
the poson equation very simple equation
not so simple for machine learning it
turns out but it has never seen the
poson equation remotely so so the
phenomena are different the input output
map is different because earlier it was
initial data to solution at a later time
now this is from a forcing term to the
solution boundary conditions are
different um steady state time dependent
so there are many many differences right
this would be a good example where the
models might not work and uh what would
you expect if you show this to a model
that has been trained on fluid flows,
it'll probably move these gausians
around as if it was a fluid flow. But it
turns out that even with one sample,
this is not the case. Uh one one image
pair, right? And it sees that and what
the foundation model does is that it
more or less diffuses it a little bit.
By 16 samples, it has learned some some
sense of diffusion, right? And this is
and by 128 samples it gets an almost
perfect solution. And this is true when
I transfer the entire latent space. But
if I freeze the latent space, this is
also true in some sense that uh the
information is there in the latent
space. It is slower but still by 16
samples it has learned some sort of
diffusion and it's not sort of
propagating it as a fluid flow. So this
tells us and this is very encouraging in
some sense that some rich physical
representations have been learned and
this is what is being leveraged right
and this this augers very well for the
future. Okay, let me what all that this
showed is there is some feasibility that
these islands that are hitherto
disconnected in some sense are connected
right otherwise there wouldn't be uh
this foundation model wouldn't be
working let me just directly go what
we're doing now we're sort of scaling it
up uh still work very much in progress
we are making it uh 3D with point clouds
and so on diffusion models and so on
some very positive preliminary results
but uh maybe perhaps the next time it
will be really sort of at a large scale.
So let me just summarize my findings. So
all that I wanted to convey is that uh
if you have PDEs uh machine learning
models are getting to be very effective
neural PT sort of particularly in 2D on
cartigian grids I I sort of maintain
that this is a solved problem uh that
things are very mature now on arbitrary
domains in 3D it's still sort of
evolving but we are getting there means
as I said graphs and transformers seems
to be a very powerful combination even
for the most difficult PDS multiscale
chaotic PDS diffusion models seem to do
the trick. But the challenge is sample
efficiency. You have to uh more more
data you throw in the better results you
get. So the question is for limited
samples how are you going to make these
models work. I think the only route at
the moment that is promising in my view
are foundation models and so far these
are still small scale. So they need to
be scaled up and there's plenty of
interesting stuff that is going to
happen in the next 3 four years. So
thank you very much for your attention
and I finished one minute.
That's okay.
>> Thank you so much for the nice talk.
Very nice. Very nice.
>> I think there many many people who asked
questions on the chat but uh
>> yeah there are two people who asked the
question.
>> How do I
>> let's do that. Uh Sumant uh if you're
there can you actually unmute yourself
and ask your question
that way. Um
>> I don't see the question at all.
>> Well I see the question but uh I think
it it's better you know the person who
has a question actually asked the
question directly.
>> Sumant are you there?
>> Yeah. Yeah I'm here. Can you hear me?
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Uh thank you professor Misha that was an
amazing uh talk and I mean most of us
have been familiar with your work for a
long time now and we knew all the
amazing work you know all the amazing
work you do so thank you so much for the
opportunity so my question is much
regarding to like the initial parts of a
presentation that is when you're
introducing like Nicolola Kovach's
kernelbased methods are most of them
based on the uh approx I mean are most
of them based on the approximation on
the linear subspace as per like Chen and
Chen's original operator learning
theorem
No, they are actually based on
nonlinear.
Well, actually I don't see a huge
difference. Uh in Nick's paper, I helped
them with that particular bit where they
showed that which is version from Chen
and Chen. This can be rewritten in this
uh in in the same spirit you know. So in
some sense the form that I wrote down is
very very general
but it's not linear. Where is it now? So
let me let me just quickly get to it so
that I can explain it. This is the
general form right. So deep I think it
is there in their paper they also
acknowledge that I helped them set set
this particular argument up is that you
can you can realize deepon nets uh also
in this in this setting but that doesn't
mean that everything in the setting
reduces to that no so that's why we
proved this theorem about fno that was
the first first attempt that you you
don't that theorem of deep net that
genench style theorem doesn't work here
because it's not a linear method and
what destroys this are the fact that
this guy is done pointwise, you know, it
does not combine across a basis, but it
applies the nonlinearity to the entire
subspace. So, you cannot view it as a
linear subspace method. But of course, a
linear subspace method can be viewed in
this sort of general nonlinear setting.
So there is there there is an argument
to be made that uh in fact the most
general version of this is done by a
student of mine former student of mine
Samuel Lanthala who has mentioned many
many times and what Samuel has shown uh
with others Jong Lee and Andrew Stewart
is that as long as you have some
nonlinearity which could be pointwise
and as long as you have some spatial
averaging you can learn any operator. So
you don't need any linear projection
nothing just non-local averaging and
linear or local nonlinearity are good
enough
but this is a very sort of I think this
is more or less the edge. So as long as
you have even just an average and then
you apply nonlinearity that's that's
good enough.
>> Okay. Uh I have one follow-up question
to that and I think it's a little more
anecdotal but uh I mean on our
experience all the physics informed
version of all this all this operator
learning based methods
>> uh if we are directly using the weak
form of the PDEs and not working on the
strong forms how does it differ in terms
of like like the metrics for example
speed and stuff like that
>> uh it differs on a lot of things. First
of all, it's very difficult to get the
physics informed version of these things
working because uh there is an
understanding now that if you do physics
informed learning the way let's say it
has been around in the pins community
including me for that matter there's an
essential conditioning problem that uh
this oper and we also showed this
mathematically that the training process
will be illitioned because it depends on
the hermission square of the operator.
So if you have a lelassian then the
training is behaving more or less like
the blasslassian and the blasslassian is
very ill conditioned operator but if you
work with a weak form then it will
behave like the llassian because some
derivatives are thrown to the test
function right so it should be better
but then why do you need this means uh
we one of the advantages of physics
informed neural networks for instance is
that you don't need a grid you don't
need basis functions and so on right
>> so but so it is uh I think there is
people can disagree with me of course
but at least I haven't been able to make
the physics informed versions of this
neural operators work because slowly
people are understanding how to
condition physics informed neural
networks where the inputs are just space
and time right yeah
>> but now your input is a field your
output is a field this is very very hard
to this is very very hard to condition
means the perhaps the best person is my
postoc Mario Zinhoer and I have asked
this for a year and he's not been able
to do it till now. So I think this is a
very very hard question.
>> Okay. Well, let's move on to next
question. Um thank you um Suman for
asking the questions. James um would you
like to unmute yourself?
>> Uh yeah, by the way, hi Sid. Uh good to
see you again. If you remember, we did a
a paper when I was at Twitter in 2022.
>> Yes, of course I know what I know him
very well.
So, so this was the PDS for neural
network architectures, right? Instead of
the other way around.
>> Yes, of course.
>> Um, so just my question quickly when
when you were showing the the pictures
of um I guess the pressure pressure
fields on the surface of the car of the
car and the airplane, it struck me that
in these methods you're throwing away
the volume simulation and it's
essentially a direct map from the
geometry to uh pressure fields.
um which seems like the internal
workings of the neural network's doing a
lot maybe it's doing a finite volume sim
inside the internal don't know what
you're thinking
>> so this is a very very good question
James you always ask good questions as I
remember you but indeed in this
particular case we have done that but
there is no reason not to take the
volume into account in fact uh in the
next version I'm sure that we will we'll
take the volumetric fields into account
uh Johannes Brownstead letter and his
group they have taken the volumetric
fields into account and they get better
results. But uh just thinking in terms
of maps right just thinking in terms of
maps you know that the so you have a
operator which goes from the shape to
the flow this is hopefully a well-
definfined operator and then you have
the trace right but if the if the if the
manifold if the solution itself is well
behaved then the trace is a very nice
linear operator so composing the two um
is still a viable option means I think
you still have uh enough enough sort of
expressivity in that in that process So
I I do agree that uh the ideal thing
would be to learn a finite volume
simulator but I'm pretty sure that the
machine learning algorithm is not doing
that because there's no reason why it
should compose the two when it can learn
the map directly. But I agree with you
that it should be that the map should be
learned to the volume but uh you know
yeah most people are learning the
surface so just to be comparative we we
did that but we we can do the volume not
a problem and it should be like that.
Thanks. Hope to see you in the future
>> hopefully.
>> Okay. Well, thank you. Thank you for the
question, James. And next phase out, do
you want to be possible to ask one more
question?
>> Go ahead. Is it related?
>> Uh, it's well, it's a different
question, I guess. Uh, I'm sorry. Put it
in the chat actually if you wanted to
say. I I had just hadn't finished typing
it, but
>> Okay. Well, the phase I'll um, you know,
put his question first. So can we
>> Oh sure sure first
>> I will answer both.
>> Yeah sure sure sure.
>> Um yeah my question is so yeah I mean
this uh foundation model is very very
inspiring. So uh so did you find
learning this uh foundation model of
operator learning and the uh school
model in the division model are they
kind of complimentary? Do you share the
same model ways? Do you find you know
trends to be
>> complimentary to each other or
>> there is there is no reason why they
can't be the same. Uh they were not the
same because these were parallel
projects at that time. At the moment we
have some efforts where they are the
same and they they seem to work well in
the limited test that you have. But uh I
think that's that's not important
because both in the foundation model as
well as in the in the diffusion model
the detail the model has to be
reasonable. And I think uh it has to
have a transformer. If you don't have a
transformer, I think it will be very
hard to accumulate the kind of
information. But uh they could be the
same model. In fact, at the moment, we
have a very similar in fact even the
same model in both cases uh which is
doing very very very well. and uh but uh
as it is published these are they're
related to each other because what you
know swin is a form of transformer that
you've used which is vit with a but
there are some convolutions but I think
these are these are sort of minor
details that that's not not essential in
some sense to to the inner workings of
these models it's more the nature of the
training the data and so on that are
that are more vital
>> thank you
>> okay well thank you. Well, Elen, it's
your turn.
>> Sorry. So, um, uh, yeah, sorry about
that earlier. I didn't see the other
question. Um, yeah. Um, I'm actually
really interested in the question or the
concept of probability distribution
function learning that you used for
chaotic dynamics. I think that's really
important for pushing the field forward.
Um, and I I think that the strategy that
you're ultimately doing in that
situation is you're looking for what the
dynamical systems community calls ruel
polycott resonances
and
>> yes yes go ahead. Yeah, I know
>> is that the that that the spectrum of
those resonances is discreet rather than
continuous as it is for the chaotic
system.
And so I was wondering if you have any,
you know, what your own perspective is
on that and if you'd actually tried
looking for ruel polycott resonances of
dynamical systems like simple systems
you know you could do many different
types or whatever you know
>> okay I can give you my own perspective
which will probably not be very popular
in my opinion Laurens system is far from
being easier than Navia Stokes is
probably harder than Navia Stokes it
does not have it does not have some of
the smoothing effects that uh real
fluids have. So I think those kind of
systems that you described and sort of
the finer properties like the invariant
measure that you talked about these are
very very hard concepts and to even
contemplate understanding them in
infinite dimensional setting like with
Navia Stokes is certainly above my pay
grade. I I don't even want to attempt
that. I do believe that it's actually
simpler to learn now his talks like the
kind that we showed than Lawrence.
Lawrence is even harder because you know
this is there is um yeah I don't have a
theorem to that effect but just
intuitively the the spread of these
measures is better for these books than
for than for Laurens. I don't know the
mechanism for that right. So of course
we have tried diffusion models on lorens
and other peoples have tried diffusion
models on lurens and this has worked
reasonably well. So that's uh that goes
without saying but I would still
maintain that that's a harder problem
just trying to get those resonances out
and so on. This is a very hard problem.
So I don't know if uh if this technology
is already able to do that. I my
suspicion is probably not you know
because those are sort of high order
effects and at the moment what it is
very good at is getting the sort of
basics of this distribution correct but
to get the entire distribution on a
function space is a very hard hard thing
maybe it needs more data I I don't know
that but already this is very data data
heavy so but it's a very good question
it's sometimes I I wonder and then I say
okay it's you know above my pay grade to
try and do this for Navia Stokes
So,
>> okay. Well, thank you. Um, wow. Okay.
So, I
>> there are many many questions.
>> Yeah, I was about to ask questions but
um I don't get to do that.
>> Robert, yes, please.
>> I have one question. May I ask please?
>> Sure. Uh uh the robot is first. Um
robot, are you there?
>> I have lost complete track.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm here. I I had an open
question. and someone else will go
before me. Um why you said that um the
transformers and the foundation models
that you've seen and this continuous
operator seem to perform better than
CNN's. Do you have any idea why?
uh
probably because um yeah so I I can
speculate on this but I don't have any
cast iron evidence so I'll probably uh
keep it to myself but roughly speaking I
think what's going on with transformers
is that because the in a in a way they
are this sort of nonlinear data
dependent kernel it's it's sort of very
degenerate you know it uh it is it's
difficult to sort of in a way have a low
rank representation so if If you have
data that is not having okay this is
very rough and I don't have a theorem to
justify it okay but let me tell you my
rough intuition here so CNN's are very
good at sort of learning many of these
models are very good at learning low-
rank representations if there are any
right but in a foundation model probably
when you have multiple distributions and
so on it's not obvious at all that there
there is a low rank distribution out
there so maybe transformers because you
know that kernels are very nonlinear
maybe they fit that fit that much
better. This this this could be a
potential mechanism. I'm not able to
distinguish them with any hard theorem
because at the level of universal
approximation everything is universal at
the level of some approximation theory
everything is nice. So I but I do
believe that the nature of the softmax
kernel the fact that it is in some sense
degenerate and it's very difficult to be
represented by sort of a linear subspace
as someone asked maybe that is actually
a good thing that it's able to sort of
learn much more highdimensional latent
spaces that that are that are there but
this just intuition I don't have any
theorem or any sort of hard evidence
backing it so it's really open question
but no one has been able to answer that
in computer vision for instance right
because before transformers came in uh
units were very very popular or unit
type architectures were very very
popular but I think uh at least for
foundation models no one uses them
people all use transformers so there
must be some some mathematical reason no
one has been to the best of my knowledge
been able to answer that so we just see
this also in physical systems
>> yeah I was just curious because I've
seen more math here than I often see in
a lot of neural net stuff. So I was
wondering if you had had more math
thing. It also drives me nuts. I really
want someone to answer it.
>> Maybe maybe in a maybe in a couple of
years, but at the moment I I don't have
a theorem. So
>> all right. Uh Samantha
Samantha, can you unmute? Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sorry, I was me. So I
have one more question and it goes back
to Elon's question of learning like
probability distributions and stuff like
that. So I was thinking that uh like um
if we think about going for more like
traditional variational autoenccoders or
similar methods right where we infer
like we have a like we have a prior and
input the posterior. How about how about
instead of using a naive gausian prior
or something like that, we first
pre-train uh like a first we pre-train
some other machine learn probabilistic
model based on similar data set or at
least of the same fidelity and then use
that learn distribution as a prior.
Would that would that help?
uh perhaps I I have never tried that
because you see autoenccoders are very
useful in to learn representations but
we want not just to learn
representations we want to make
predictions right so it's sort of uh
perhaps I I don't know that it it could
happen but uh there's there's no
guarantee that there is an automatic way
of finding out what is a close enough
distribution what's a good prior then
you're then you're lost in the in the
business of finding a good prior which
is also what I have been doing or we
have been doing right because we put a
good prior because we we understand a
little bit how PDS behave and then we
put some things in the pre-training data
set. So we have provided a good prior
and then we let the transformer do the
work rather than going through this sort
of variational autoenccoder machinery
but this could be a viable option right
but the difficulty would be the choice
of the prior as always so
>> um Rakkesh
>> yeah uh I can go ahead thank uh thank
you for your presentation Dr.
Uh so my doubt is like uh if uh we have
a potential uh direction in the future
to towards the foundational model it
could be promising for multifysics uh
too. uh in that case uh so whenever we
are trying to solve a multifys make a
multiysics prediction uh by pre-training
that model with the different uh pdes in
such cases uh is there any possibility
that uh we can override the assumption
we made uh like some of the paper made
like kawachi paper made like the banax
space is continuous in nature because
there are possibilities that some PD uh
multifysics PD can go to discontinuous
approximation and stuff.
>> No, I don't think they made that.
Perhaps they made that assumption but
this has been relaxed in many many many
many cases including in my own papers
there's nothing there is nothing uh so
you mean that if the operator itself is
not continuous.
>> Mhm. Yeah.
>> This is probably no but again I think in
one of our papers we even worked with
measurable operators. So this is this is
fine. This is
>> okay. So his paper with Lanthala and
Kanyak is it's at the level of
measurable measurable operators.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> So this is not an issue.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Well I finally I get to ask
questions.
So going back to foundation models.
>> Yeah.
>> Um I I totally agree that we lack the
formal definition of what foundation
model is. Um our recent paper tries to
>> I know
>> tackle that issue.
>> I know. Um
>> okay so you read that paper?
>> Yes. Sure. Sure.
>> Awesome. Awesome. Um so one of the you
know key challenges we raised in the
paper was um you know in the
computational science
um each sample
size
would be uh very huge. I mean you know
for example comparing to the large
language models or digital models um
each sample is tokens which whose size
is what some some sort of bytes units
right.
>> Yes. Yes. But we are dealing with um the
simulation data um whose vector size
could be millions or billions and you
know just to you know you know store
that in the memory it it may take a
gigabytes just for the one single data
point. Um so because of that um
foundation model
uh needs you know to generate a lot of
samples right I mean as you pointed out
you you need to you know bring the
diverse data sets um and train the
pre-trained model
>> and apply that to downstream task
various different downstream task um but
the single sample size the data size is
humongous like generating the big data
like the diverse data itself is very
challenging. Um so how do you how would
you overcome that issue that challenge
you know in the development of your own
foundation? Yeah, this is a very very
good question and there are two ways in
which I fully agree with you actually
there is a challenge here a very let's
say severe challenge in some sense but
there is uh to me there are two two
points here first of all let's say in
terms of simulation there's no question
that we have to resolve a certain scale
right otherwise we can't represent
interesting phenomena and so on and the
time step has to be dictated by the CFL
number and so on and so forth but once
we have done the simulation Once we are
finished with the simulation and we have
humongous amounts of data the question
that I ask myself is I'm going to make
errors right means there will always be
errors at some level and in pre-training
you can even make large errors it does
not really matter to some extent how
much of errors can I make if I keep on
sort of compressing the data right and
this compression can be just by physical
downsampling that I take randomly some
of the points and not all the points or
it could be in terms of tokenization
that I tokenize it into some suitable
space and so on. And my claim is that
the errors compared to simulation when
you do downsampling or tokenizing or
whatever errors that you're going to
make are going to be much smaller than
you would have simulated at that scale.
In other words, let's say that I
simulate a turbulent flow at 100 cube, I
don't see anything, right? But if I
simulate it at a,00and cube which is a
very expensive simulation but downs
sample it at 100 cube I still have quite
a bit of information contained in it
right mean it's still the thousand cubed
it's just an interpolation or a sampling
error that is there I don't want to do
it in let's say in fia space that's not
that's not the right way but uh this
this is uh sort of there is a degree of
freedom there that that you don't need
that kind of fidelity there is a
compressibility in the data if you have
no compressible ility then it's white
noise and there's no chance right then
we cannot do anything but as I have
repeatedly argued even for turbulent
fluid flows then it is not uh not like
that the distributions are well behaved
and other things are well behaved so
there's a possibility that the
compression once you have simulated the
simulation there's no choice you have to
do it at the necessary resolution the
compression can help you in this case
and that's the only route you know there
should be enough compression and I keep
on telling that the pre-train model
doesn't have to be very accurate. You
know, it has to learn some useful
representation and when you go to
fine-tuning, when you go to some
concrete task, you anyway don't have a
lot of samples. So, there is some degree
of freedom there.
>> And uh whether this is enough, this is
still an open question, right? But
>> but uh there is there is a degree of
freedom that there there there is a way
out.
>> Okay. Okay. Well, I mean I mean I I I
mean you you mentioned compression and
also the downsampling but um by doing so
you're losing some information
>> some information for sure. The question
is how much of information is necessary
>> necessary or not. Yes, exactly. That
will depends on the applications and
>> this will depend on how well I I fully
agree with you that at a downstream task
level this should not be done because
you need correct results right but in
pre-training I'm not convinced that we
need all the information out there and
there is some degree of freedom but I
fully agree that this needs to be
investigated right means this field is
like one or two years old so I'm sure as
a community in two three years we'll be
able to find good answers
>> yeah yeah we we are heading there um so
So the my following question is about
the downstream um downstream uh task uh
as you just mentioned um yes I mean
downstreaming to different PTE um so
that's awesome so it's check mark for
the um you know the predicting being
able to predict the uh the solutions for
the uh across the different PTE problems
that that's awesome but how about you
change the domain geometry like from the
circular to the rectangular or even 2D
to 3D and or
>> you change the boundary conditions or
>> um you know well material properties or
initial conditions or and and so on.
>> Those are uh very very relevant
questions. Some of them are already
answered in our paper because we changed
the material properties, we changed the
initial conditions, we changed the
boundary conditions. Some of them will
be answered in the next one because we
already have results where we change
domains and it works very well and we
change there have been some master's
thesis which have already done that and
we change uh also in this paper I think
the it's already out there this paper
when at all the you can see that we did
some transfer learning where we had
different kinds of shapes um a square um
I don't know circle and then we
transferred to ellipse and and so on.
>> So this is already out there in the
domain. So 2D 3D as you can see I have a
I have an example here which is uh
hopefully coming out soon. Where is the
example? I'll just show it. And so you
can see that this is actually trained
with a 2D checkpoint. So this has 2D
features in it. This is from scratch and
you can see that there's a big
difference. So even with the 2D
checkpoints it sort of transfers well to
3D. And I know that people from Shinhua
also did some of it and so that again as
I said that there are some good
indications. Okay. So
>> so so
>> uh fine tuning you're using the transfer
learning.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> Um to adapt to the different geometry.
>> Yes.
>> So my next question would be how
expensive that principal learning?
>> Uh it's very very compared to learning
from scratch it's very very cheap
because uh you just uh you You need only
a few few samples, right? Means this is
sort of this is where the in in our
paper we have done that sort of a
comparison that how much of compute do
you need in order to do the finetuning.
It's much less than scratch training
simply because as you can see with a
fewer samples you can get by with uh you
know the same error as you would have
done with a lot lot more samples. Right?
So this is the this is the way to go.
It's not not expensive compared to
pre-training. Pre-training is very
expensive.
>> Oh. Oh. Well, um looking forward to the
next paper. Um
>> now I think I'm a bit tired after
I also have to make my kids sleep. So
>> yeah, sure. Sure. Well, thank thank you
so much. Um so you know listening to you
know that demonstration of the next uh
the papers uh you know generalizing to
the different domains uh that sounds
very promising. Um and yes and since you
have read our paper on on the defining
foundation model in computational
science we we introduce you know list of
this criteria
>> and I I see that your next paper is get
the check mark for all
>> sure sure we'll do that don't worry
>> good job see okay well let's
>> thank you so much
>> you know yeah let's wrap up the um
>> byebye everyone thanks for staying so
Yeah. Bye.
>> Thank you. Thank you. See it. Bye.